hi my name is eric um and i'm here today
to talk a little bit about our work um
on how sars cov2 can affect the central
nervous system i'm from yale
immunobiology and from the u.s hockey
lab
so before we kind of dive into the data
i just want to
acknowledge everyone that's been really
involved in this project it was a huge
effort especially in the beginning of
the pandemic when you know resources
were hard to get and also people were
hard to come by um everyone stepped up
and
really worked as a team in order to make
this happen and so a huge shout out to
everyone
and specifically chris bartley and chad
lang were co-first authors on the
projects that i'll be presenting today
so a special shout out to them
so
going back to the to the beginning of
the pandemic it was pretty evident early
on that there was definitely a central
nervous system component to various cov2
and covet 19.
this was really seen in kind of the
clinical manifestation of the disease
people really started looking at what
the neurological association
was
how there were both neurological and
neuropsychiatric complications
and
these are all based on clinical data
showing anywhere from you know just a
loss of smell uh which which has been a
very characteristic character of you
know corbin 19 and also associated with
some of the
neurological findings
to full-blown encephalitis or like
encephalopathies that
were more indicative of how
cova might be affecting the brain
directly
and since then a lot of
lots has been um kind of discovered and
a lot has changed and we know now a lot
more about the disease and how it might
be affecting the central nervous system
you know this is this was a very nice
summary done by lou at all i'm showing
that
both by rtpcr immunohistochemistry many
groups now have identified the virus
might be present in the brain
and it's associated with a very diverse
amount of kind of phenotypic findings
right such as microglia activation
estrogliosis
all these things
very similar to how there's a huge
diversity in the kind of symptoms that
patients are
now feeling right
so in in my head the way i really see it
is that
the reason we have such diverse clinical
findings must be because the the
magnitude of how the virus affects the
central nervous system
differs
by a whole lot and you can think about
the different ways the virus can
infiltrate right it can be going through
the blood-brain barrier or the
chloroplexus barrier
it might be
coming in directly into the brain but
also kind of non-specific
more of a systemic inflammation or a
systemic inflammation that's affecting
the brain through cytokine signaling or
other things
so you know now as as a community and as
a as a scientific group uh we've all
been looking at the many different ways
that stars cov2 can infect or affect the
central nervous system
but when we first started
thinking about this question during the
pandemic we really set out to answer a
very very simple question
whether cancers called v2 infect neural
tissues
and in order to answer that
we we combined a multi-pronged approach
where we utilized the brain organoid
model
we developed and used already developed
mass models of stars cody2
and finally with our collaborators we
were able to use postmortem brain
samples to kind of elucidate how stars
cov2 may affect the brain
and we really started this
as early as i think april of last year
so
back then you know we didn't know
what was possible and it was very
important to us to figure out you know
what the possibilities of this disease
was this virus was
so we decided to first use stars cov2 um
in using brain human brain organoids and
we were not the first group to do this
there were many groups at the time that
were kind of working on a similar
question
and the idea was
you know during the zika virus
pandemic or epidemics there was
groups that were able to use human brain
organoids to model zika virus effect on
neural tissues
we wanted to see if stars cov2 can be
affecting neural tissues
so
naturally once we got a good infection
going we asked the most basic question
cancerous cov2 infection
result in cell death
and overwhelmingly we immediately saw
this you know huge infection along with
a lot of cell death marked here in green
right by the tunnel staining
we were extremely excited
but what we were really kind of
i guess shocked to see
was that
the cells that were infected shown in
red here were not the cells that were
dying
in fact
you can see here there's almost
virtually no overlap between the cells
that are marked in red right the
infected cells in the cells that are
going through cell death the green
tunnel positive cells
when we quantify this
we were you know overwhelmingly in the
whole organoid we were able to see that
most of the tunnel positive cells were
not infected with stars kobe 2.
giving us this idea that dying cells
were not infected with starscoby2 and
even within
a single organoid
in different regions of the organoid you
can see here very clearly that
stars cov2 infected
cells um
are neighbored by a lot of tunnel
positive cells
shown in the yellow box
compared to the white box where if there
is no infection happening cell death is
also not occurring in those regions
so to better kind of probe this question
of what's actually going on and why are
the cells
that are not infected actually dying in
these organoids
we decided to use single cell rna
sequencing to to answer this question
so by using single cell sequencing of
the human brain organoid we were able to
come up with a variety of different cell
types in the organoid
and in addition we were able to clearly
detect which cells
were infected by looking for the thyroid
cov2 mrna
and you can see here 96 hours after an
infection
we had a large amount of organoids and
our cells in the organoids infected with
artichobi2
so to see what was happening
transcriptionally after we infected them
we first decided to compare it with a
very canonical neurotrophic virus like
we talked about the zika virus
and to our surprise what we noticed was
that the genes that are upregulated in
zika virus um
after
or it does the genes that are
upregulated in the organoid after zika
virus infection virtually had no overlap
with the genes that were upregulated
after a sarcob2 infection shown here in
the bottom
in fact if we take the genes and look at
the pathways that are involved in um
in these two infection models they were
very very different and we have on the
top kind of shared gene signature of
some sort of
you know foreign infection occurring
right foreign stress or foreign stimuli
however while zika virus was able to
upregulate pathways related to kind of
type 1 interferons and immune responses
these canonical immune responses that we
expect to see
as far as kovi2 infected neuronal cells
actually showed none of these pathways
and rather they were going through cell
cycle pathways and more metabolically
active pathways
to even look at it more granularly we
took the cells that were actually
infected in a specific organoid and
compared it to the neighboring cells
right the cells that were not infected
but in the infected conditions
in the cells that were infected by cyrus
cov2 we were able to see that they were
going through a hyperoxic
pathway along with increase of many
different metabolic pathways
and
the neighboring cells
were actually going through a response
of hypoxia and they were having
decreased oxygen levels and going
through the cell death um and the cell
deaths we noticed right from from the
previous things and to make sure that
this was indeed truly happening we we
validated our findings by standing for
different markers of
hypoxia
and here you can see that once sars cov2
infection occur
the local environment and the organoid
became much more hypoxic
as you can see here by the hydroxyl
probe that we used
so we now had a kind of a working model
of what was what might be going on the
the thyroscopy ii infected these
neuronal cells and that actually didn't
result in that but increase in metabolic
activity um
to replicate itself and by doing that
the cells then
were sequestering
um the nutrients needed to survive from
neighboring cells and the neighboring
cells were the ones that were actually
dying from the the consequence of the
infection
this is all very exciting and
interesting but as you know organoids
don't have the capability to have all
the cells that we would normally find in
a
normal central nervous system
so we decided to adopt a
couple of different models of sars cole
v2 for for mice
um
and
very quickly we were able to actually
see that
stars cov2 had a huge neuroinvasive
potential in even in mice
um
of course the mice uh require uh
exogenous ace to human ace to expression
but once the the receptor expression is
present and the the cells are able to
you know harbor these viruses and allow
them to replicate at large amounts
and you can see uh many many neurons in
different types of different parts of
the brain could be infected
as seen here and to our um this is a
idisco imaging that one of our
collaborators nico from
paris
helped us with and you can see the
cerebellum is mostly spared in this mice
but
most all of the other parts of the brain
are highly infected
and
using niko's
idisco method he was also able to map
out the vasculature and that was present
in these the brains of the mice
and we thought that the vasculature if
if there was truly this hypoxic kind of
response that was occurring from
sarcolevy to infection then the
vasculature might actually be also
changing in in the in the
in the brains of these mice
we were able to calculate the densities
of the mice the the vessels in the mice
and what we saw was after infection the
the vessel densities
were
changed significantly
and this also was very much aligned with
hot spots of virus infection very
similar and
very similar to what we saw in the
organoid
so we were very excited about this idea
and we have kind of ongoing projects on
kind of looking at this further
and then finally
at the same time you know there was this
big need and a big excitement to see if
the virus can actually infect
human brain tissue
and at the beginning of the pandemic it
was very scary and people were trying to
avoid aerosolizing any sort of
you know
virus
so it was hard for us to get tissues but
our collaborators once again from france
really pulled through
and they were able to obtain
patient samples who passed away from
sarcobi2 and what we saw was that
in certain patients brains we were able
to see sarco v2 positive neurons
and what was most interesting to us
about this was that in other brain
infections such as like herpes virus or
zika virus or west nile virus
we we tend to see this huge influx of
lymphocytes or other immune cells that
are contributing to to the damage right
while it's clearing the brain
however in the sars cov2 infected brains
we didn't see the same sort of huge
inflammatory response we saw infected
neurons but a different type of kind of
follow-up and response that occur
and this is
consistent with like what other groups
have seen
we saw these
regions of micro infarcts and
hemorrhages that were
resembling
kind of many possible many strokes
and what we saw was that in these
regions of micro infarction we also saw
a higher um
ray or higher amounts of spike um stars
kobe 2 staining
and it it was very reminiscent of kind
of what we were seeing in both the mouse
model and the organoid model
and although we haven't been able to
completely follow up with the
mechanistic understanding of why or how
this is happening in patients i know a
lot of groups have different
interesting hypotheses and they're
working on it so i i think it's a very
exciting time for this kind of research
so
you know with that we were able to
really answer this basic question of
cancerous kobe to infect neural tissues
and while we were doing this we were
able to answer a few more additional
questions using the models that we
developed
and one big thing that i thought was
very important was
this idea of what receptor the virus was
using to infect the brain
and this was especially important
because
everyone in the beginning was you know
looking for ace2 expression in every
organ possible
and relating that to whether stars cov2
might be infecting that organ
and similarly
neuroscientists and people in
neuroscience and neuroimmunologists were
interested in the same question
can start cov2 affect the brain through
ace2
one thing we did was
we first checked for ace2 levels in our
organoids and we saw that the human
brain organoids expressed high levels of
base 2.
and then what we did was we blocked
the h2
receptor using an eastern antibody and
then try to infect the organoids
neutralize or when we blocked the
receptor then we no longer had an
infection showing that h2 was indeed the
method that's our cov2 was infecting
neural tissues
and then we were also able to show um
that
h2 was expressed in human brain
postmortem tissue and this was very
important because
compared to other organs h2 expression
level by rna is very low in neural
tissues and i think this kind of was a
big question mark and
whether
with such low levels of ace to mrna
stars cov2 can infect the brain
and so what we show here is that
h2 levels
in different clusters in our organoids
actually do not correlate with the
amount of cells that are infected
in that cluster so for example
some of these clusters have very high
levels of aids too
mrna but they're not really being
infected at a high percentage while some
other cells with very low levels of mrna
base 2 they're still getting infected
very well
indicating that actually the mrna level
of h2 is not
fully correlated correlated with the
protein levels of ace2 in these tissues
and
um in data that i'm not showing today we
also look at
how
h2 levels in the mice brain are
somewhere in the range of like 10 000
fold lower than the lungs however
these human h2 knock-in mice
tend to succumb to brain infections and
not lung infections
indicating that ace2 really acts as a
gateway of
the virus entering the cell of interest
but does not necessarily
mean like high levels higher levels
equal doesn't mean it's more susceptible
to the virus
um along those lines and testing the h2
requirement we we also wanted to make
sure on the other end that sars code v2
required um
the spike to bind to the h2 to infect
these
brain organoids we are very lucky um to
get uh to have a collaborator who
provided a spinal uh css from patients
with colvin 19.
and then we were we were able to show
that the csf in these patients actually
had
neutralizing antibodies against
the
sarcob2
and with that we did a similar essay
where we used the human brain organoid
and co-incubated the virus with
the csf in order to see if the
antibodies in the csf can truly prevent
infection of
the organoids
and what we saw was similar to blocking
ace2
that the csf antibodies were sufficient
in blocking infection of neural tissues
and with that we were able to kind of
definitively show that saris cov2 can
infect neural tissues through the route
of ace2
with the csf that we were able to obtain
we were able to do some additional
experiments and this is in a in a
separate manuscript that chris bartley
at ucsf and i worked on
and
one of the things that
really kind of
was very exciting to us was
by using saris cov2 almost as a model we
were able to kind of think about
other
effects that viral infections can have
on the central nervous system
um in in in human biology and in a more
kind of broad setting
so one of the things that we we noticed
was that
coven 19 uh resulted in
neutralizing or blocking antibodies
against spike
in both the csf shown on the left and in
the plasma of same patients
but what we noticed uh was
while they all
were able to produce this anti-spike
antibody
the epitopes that were present in the
csf and then the plasma were very unique
to each compartment
so you can see here the s552589
epitope is very highly expressed in the
csf but much more lower in the plasma
while
the
818855 epitope is low in the csf but
high in in the plasma indicating that
you know the two compartments are
actually immunologically unique
um and this was actually shown in uh
more recent papers by the kelowna and
you know the kidness groups um looking
at kind of
uh
bone marrow like skull bone marrow and
meninges uh native b cells and
neutrophils
but also you know the immune responses
that we we imagine that's occurring in
the csf versus the plasma really
are unique to each other and we have to
think about the two compartments as a as
a separate entity
and in order to kind of dive into this a
little bit more we we were able to
create a new mouse model of stars cov2
using human ace ii over expression using
an adeno-associated virus and that can
be checked out by a paper a postdoc in
our lab then israelo and i wrote
last year
and by using this adopting this model we
were able to
localize the infection the sarcoidominal
infection and very specific compartments
of the mouth so either just the lung as
shown in the top here in both the lung
and the brain shown in the middle here
or just in the brain
and with this we were able to answer
kind of this
you know long mysterious question about
how can we use csf to understand what's
going on in the central nervous system
so
what we did was we infected um these
mice that were only expressing you know
human h2 in the lung only in the brain
or both the lung in the brain and then
tracked antibody responses in each
compartment
so first when we only infect it in the
lung
we we expect to see the antibodies um
you know be produced only in the lung
and the serum right and then the brain
and the csf there's very little antibody
responses
which is very expected
when we look at
infection that's occurring in both the
lung and the brain we now see antibodies
at high levels in all four compartments
including lung serum brain and csf shown
here at yellow
finally when we isolated the infection
only into the brain what we saw was that
the lung and the serum actually had
significantly lower amounts of antibody
being produced i mean actually the brain
and csf antibodies were very sensitive
to detecting
that infection in the brain was
occurring
and to kind of look at this even in more
detail we also checked viral titers
during this time
of the different compartments and in
mice that were infected in both the lung
and the brain
we were able to find high levels of the
virus
in the brain tissue and the lung tissue
itself
but we're unable to detect high levels
of the virus by qpcr in the csf or the
serum
and i think this is especially important
in thinking about kind of clinical
relevance of how we
tend to think about viral infections in
the cns
for many many
you know reasons one being access to
brain tissue being very difficult we use
csf as a surrogate for understanding
what's going in the brain
that also means many assays and many you
know diagnostic tools are designed to
detect and uh virus levels right to pcr
or whatever it may be in the css however
as shown here
that sometimes is not sensitive enough
or it's not the right kind of essay to
be able to definitively say a
neuro invasion occurred
and rather
being able to think about it with
antibodies might be more important
in making clinical diagnoses
um and then finally um today i don't
have time to go over this but i want to
give you guys a a peek at what chris
really contributed to
this project is
we were also able to show that in many
of these patients auto antibodies
against
cells in the brain
occurred in the csf of these copin 19
patients
and
chris did beautiful work using a
combination of mass spec
their
ip pull down strategies and mouse
validation um to show what the specific
target of all these auto antibodies
might be
indicating that in addition to the
response
effective immune response against covet
that occurs in these infections there's
also a dysfunctional dysregulated
autoimmune response that can occur um
giving us kind of an insight to
possibilities of why long covet might
occur
so with that
i just want to thank everyone again
especially
who
you know allowed us to use his beautiful
organoids for majority of the project
and chris who helped with the css story
and making that such an interesting and
fun project and collaboration to work
with
and of course akiko for allowing me to
perform all these experiments in their
lab and just always encouraging me
to chase any questions that i have
so thank you for your time and
i'll take in questions